welcome to on base live in your bleach
Report app I am your host Mookie Betts
and today we got a a Ron judge what's
going on brother what's up mookie how
you doing brother I'm good my man
welcome back to Cali I know this is your
crib maybe not here maybe uh a little up
North but yeah a little farther north
but man California's California's home
man so it's always good to be back here
you got your folks here um then they
don't they always got to come to these
games right yeah they don't miss it they
don't miss it man my dad grew up in in
Southern California so anytime he gets a
chance to come out to Dodger Stadium and
check out his old stomping grounds man
he eats it up so he he was coming to
games and stuff all the time when he was
younger as well yeah when he when he was
growing up he came to a lot of Dodger
games I think he snuck in a couple times
yeah yeah he had he had some fun down
here but uh
you know it was it was crazy once we
once he moved up to Northern California
man he he flipped to a Giants fan quick
but I couldn't believe it I couldn't
believe it no he's still he still enjoys
it he's still downtown so before we get
all the way into Aaron judge I want to
Rattle off some stats
some accolades I'm sorry Accu ladies
you're 20 2022 Al MVP
four-time All-Star three-time Silver
Slugger 2017 Al Rookie of the Year and
two-time home run leader
that's dope dog
that's that but and the kicker is you're
actually really really really really
really good in the Outfield
like you're you you're huge bro it seems
like when you're standing out there you
just take up the whole Outfield and then
you run like a cat dog it's a long
straws bro I got these long legs that's
I'm trying to be like you out there
that's it no you get from point A to
point B quick and then you have to rob a
homers can we show the stat there you go
right there oh yeah so 12 11 and 10 you
know what I'm saying you you rob a lot
of homers out in the last 20 Seasons you
rob a lot of homers how do you like do
you take pride in life when you when you
go I'm gonna bring that thing down uh I
try to you know the thing that you know
when you when you and Mike get up there
I mean you guys are jumping all the way
up you're reaching back you rob it for
me at six seven when I jump I got I jump
like six inches off the ground
especially at home in Yankee Stadium I
just gotta lift my glove up and I can
rob it so I think this is probably that
last one I did was maybe the best one I
kind of had to get up like you guys do
man but no it's it's fine I try to take
a lot of Pride Nicks I know the
pitcher's working hard you know
everybody out there is working hard on
defense I never wanted to be just uh
just to hit her you know like I want to
take pride in my work out there and you
do everything on the defensive end I
mean arm is great I mean like I said
everything you you're five to a player
bro so shout out to you man you know we
got it to you so I want to get get us on
this this on base off base game so it's
basically called you enter out
and
um I think I've seen
you like to you're
Taylor Swift you're you're in a you got
to be in on her right oh yeah it's on
base you're on base yeah so what's your
favorite song about that so
you know I I was early on Taylor Swift
fan when she was a little more country
oh hi we'll hide those songs that I like
we'll save those ones but something for
new stuff man you know bad blood is what
I said in this little video yeah right
here you know just so it's like it was a
good morning song when you're getting
ready you know getting ready to go to
the park you throw that on man gets in a
good mood so so in your ride to the
field you listen to Bad Blood
or is it just before I before okay
before so I'm getting dressed okay you
guys on the Right End you got to get get
your mind right there yeah man you got
to get mentally locked in so the Taylor
Swift kind of happens you know brushing
your teeth getting ready for the day
yeah Bad Blood 22. yep you know and then
and then and then and then did you did
you ever go to the ear the eras tour I
didn't I did a couple teammates did you
know we had a we had a series again
against the Padres I think then and I
have family oh yeah so everybody else
went I think Rizzo he grabbed a couple
T-shirts and sweatshirts he was at the
merch he was grabbing all the
merchandise man he was killing it did he
get you something no he didn't he didn't
oh I'm gonna take it I'll find something
oh yeah make sure you're talking okay so
what about uh Jimmy Butler you think
Jimmy Butler is going to win his first
ring you enter out on that
he is going to win his first ring in or
out
have you seen Denver right
I got my opinion
all right we can talk about it okay okay
hold on let me
I'm off base on that one okay you know
I'm a fan of Jimmy you know he's you
know what he's done the past couple
Seasons his whole career basically man
he's just a such a great competitor he
brings it every single night he elevates
his teammates
but seeing what I see with Denver The
Joker you know Jamal Murray Porter drink
man it's they just I just don't think
that he can keep up yeah there's too
many options there's too many options
they have to play too much defense and
then it's just gonna be a lot it's just
gonna be a lot but it's a fun series
though they got they got some ball
players so they do it's fun to watch
yeah we'll see I'm curious to see game
two and see how that goes and then uh
and then I'll know more but right now
I'm I'm off I'm off at the same way so
what about is I know this in New York
thing
putting bacon egg and cheese on a roll
and not a bagel or is that are you are
you are you that is that much New York
in your blood
so what is it am I bacon egg and cheese
on a roll
and not a bagel
and if you don't know right now
by the time this show is over you're
gonna find out
I'm off it right now your office yeah so
you like it on a bagel I'm a bagel guy
yeah what kind of bagel
don't even
oh this is disgusting you're the second
person I was playing my video game and
this girl she she was from New York and
she said the the garlic onion Bagel in
the morning don't hate don't hate you're
a garlic no but it's got to be loaded
with bacon egg and cheese plain if I'm
doing a plain bagel
you don't even do those yeah I don't
even do those yeah you gotta you gotta
load them up you just wake up breath
funky
golly
man see
stay over there
okay so what about this what about this
bringing your dog to work
oh I'm on base 100 percent yeah I've
seen that and you had you had man that
little bitty dog did he just fit in your
hand I mean he's not even a small dog
it's just that you just that big yeah
that's a golden that's a golden
retriever the camera is fooling you guys
man Oh I thought that was okay that yeah
okay that's the go okay right there
that's the golden retriever right there
okay oh yeah you know what so that's my
man yeah I got two dogs that's Gus
that's Gus yep he's got an older sister
Penny who's also Penny didn't want to
make the trip you know Penny's been a
Yankee Stadium and I felt like it was
time that Gus got the call up to the big
leagues okay and so and you guys had a
ball yeah that's it looked like he's
having time in his life yeah what time
was that what time were you out there so
I think it was around 12 12 30. so you
was there early yeah I had to because
some I was hoping the cameras didn't
catch me I'm trying to get out there
early oh so you run around a little bit
you know you were hoping the cameras
didn't catch you yeah and they were a
lot yeah yeah you yeah they were locked
in from the beginning but it was a good
time that was a good little good little
reset you know I try to do that every
once in a while because it's tough to
take a couple dogs to Central Park and
run around man so here I know I got the
freedom yeah you can do whatever you
need to do oh yeah oh yeah all right so
let me take take me to this because I
didn't experience this
and you did your free agency
tell me about that like how how was that
like because I've talked to some people
and some people think it's it's
stressful and some people enjoy it and
so I want to hear from your perspective
like how was it stressful was it
enjoyable
man it was stressful you know that's the
one thing like you said like
throughout our whole career all the
veteran guys are always like hey wait
till you're a free agent man it's the
best time get to choose where you want
to go you finally get to make your own
decision on you know where you want to
play and make a home and you know for me
getting drafted by the Yankees man that
was such a gift and you know I there's
no better place for me
but kind of getting to the point of okay
now I'm a free agent they didn't lock me
up it's like let's let's see what's out
there you know and he didn't take it
personally just because teams don't lock
you up that that's not a personal you
know they got to take care of their
business as well so I'm assuming you
didn't take that personally no it was
it's it's all part of it you know we we
tried contract extensions you know
before my last season it didn't work out
then you know it's my time to go out
there and play the game like I'm still a
Yankee right I still got this last year
you know something could happen during
the season and you know so I didn't take
it personal it was just part of the
business I got to go check out you know
see what's out there but man in the back
of my mind it was you know it was always
always New York man so so so there was a
tweet
um
and
what what was the Tweet can we show what
the Tweet was I don't remember I think
there was a tweet and you were you went
back home to San Fran for a little bit
right yeah I think my name changed a
little bit I think they're so
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah what
is that what was that you know anything
about that you know I was actually on a
I was on a flight
and my agent texted me said he said bro
you were stuff's going down in San Diego
right now and I'm like what are you
talking about San Diego yeah so I guess
this happened kind of at the right there
the winter meetings yeah arson judge
he's still I haven't seen a statue with
the Giants me neither it was that'd be
pretty good though but it was it was
funny like that that kind of blew up a
little bit and I started getting a
couple text messages from family and
friends and you know people with the
Yankees kind of what's going on but you
went to the Giants yeah me going to the
Giants so it was and so you were did you
get excited about that like yeah we're
going to the Giants like I didn't even
get to choose yeah the one time I get to
choose I didn't get to choose so so that
you got home the same friend were you
that was this all playing the game like
was this all like you know what I really
I really truly in my heart want to go
back to New York or did you not really I
mean you cared right yeah but like were
you like you know I just I'm open to New
Beginnings I'm open to new things you
know what what was your mindset going
through that you know
I wanted to stay in New York I always
want to be in New York but I think
looking at it I was like I think I'd
kick myself down the road if I just
didn't go through the process just check
out the process see what other teams
have to offer see what you know I got to
meet a lot of great coaches a lot of
great front offices other players with
other teams and just kind of see how
they ran things you know what their
mindset was and at the end of the day
what it came down to me was winning you
know I want to win man you won you got
two World Series rings you know back
home and
for me that's that was my main goal so
go looking through all the options
looking to all the teams we talked to it
always came back to which team's going
to give me the best opportunity to win
and you know New York is always at the
top of that list yeah so when I when I
when I had heard you were going to the
Giants
my heart kind of sank a little bit
because I was like man you don't want to
see me dog I want to see you and I want
to see you but I don't want to see you
in right field what I mean you know what
I'm saying I just didn't I'm like oh my
gosh you know the Giants they're already
it's already like a rivalry you know and
and now they're going to be
so good you know you what you were going
to add to that team and so I'm like oh
my gosh and I know I know the the media
they make this me versus you thing right
they always do that and and just just
telling you like it ain't I ain't never
felt like it's a me verse you think I I
feel like there's definitely space for
both of us to be great you know what I'm
saying and and I think that's one thing
that we've always kept in common like
every time we've come in and interact
with each other it's always been respect
you know it's always been love when I
watch you all I want you to do great and
I feel you know I can't speak for you
but I'm just telling you from my
perspective
so when I saw you sign with the Giants
bro I was I was happy
but I was hurt you know what I'm saying
but now you're back in New York so so so
is there were there any stories or
anything that kind of happened within
the free agency that that
are kind of Untold like the people that
don't see you know I'm saying like you
went to
you went somewhere and you had to do
this and you got on the plane to head
this way ahead to this place but you
weren't actually going to do you know
just little things that you may have
happened that people don't see
man
I think the biggest thing was I was at
I think it was a Sunday night football
game in Tampa watching the Bucks play
the Saints and also my agent calls me
it's like 9 9 30. 10 o'clock and he's
like hey we got to get you on a flight
out to these winter meetings I'm like oh
what are you talking about I got a
flight in two days with my wife to go
out to Hawaii we're going out there for
a little vacation what do you mean I've
got to go to San Diego he's like no we
gotta you know this stuff stuff buzzing
teams are calling like we got it we got
to get you here like
ASAP like in the morning so it was just
stressful times like that like hopping
on a flight flying all night there
staying in San Diego just for a couple
hours just to hop on another flight to
head out to Hawaii man oh so you had to
do yeah it was just in and out like a
little
covert Mission pop in there pop out and
people don't see that type of stuff man
yeah no they think it's all like you're
getting whined and dined by these teams
and everything's great man it's it's
stressful just because you're thinking
about your family you're thinking about
you know where you want to
yo keep your legacy going where you want
to start a legacy and now you have your
legacy in New York so you sign this nine
year 360. what was the first thing you
bought
I bought my wife a house I was I was
number one on my list you know she was
she was tired I had a I had a nice
little a condo apartment in Florida and
then I got a condo in New York and she's
like hey I'm I'm done with the condo the
condo yeah I need some space got some
Penny needs some grass to run around so
you know that was that was the first
thing on our list is is getting the
house and you know she's kind of what
did you buy did you buy you anything
watch something not really I'm still I'm
still waiting for these first couple
checks to come through you know all
right
so so you ain't got nothing
it's early man it's just June give me
give me some time give me some time the
first you I would have bought it or
something I ain't happy
give me a necklace or something yeah
you're right you're right I gotta you
gotta get something bro you got to get
something give me give me to
give me to All Star break I'll still
work with something I see you at the
All-Star Game
also something something so then you
became the captain of the Yankees how
how does that work like how do you get
named captain what is that process
because that's that's super dope bro the
captain of the Yankees like that's what
kids dream of and you doing it so how
did that happen
it was wild you know I was actually
I was at my parents house because my
wife and I were flying
from Northern California out to Hawaii
like I said so we were just staying at
my parents house just got back from San
Diego
it's like two three o'clock in the
morning and I'm actually hopping on a
call with Hal basically saying like hey
you know are we gonna get this deal done
I'm hearing all these other offers from
other teams I don't want to go anywhere
I want to stay here you know what are we
going to do
and he's like what's it going to take
you know I threw out some numbers it's a
done deal that's it that's it I said
yeah so he's all right Deal's done and
oh by the way
um you know Thurman Munson was my
favorite player growing up as a kid and
you know he was a Yankees Captain I want
to
I want to make you the next Yankee
captain man and man I was sitting there
on speakerphone with my wife and I got
chills I didn't know what to say I felt
like I didn't say anything for like 30
minutes she's like hitting me like you
got it you got to say something you know
so you know just hearing them say that
um and then having the press conference
in New York you know having Derek there
having Willie Randolph you know two
former captains there as well it's
it was incredible honor man it's
something that
you know you never think about you I'm
just trying to go out there just like
you every single day and be a good
teammate you know be a good competitor
you know uplift my teammates you know so
when you get that kind of title man
there's there's more responsibility but
it's still just about you going out
there and just taking it yeah what is
what is what what comes with it like
what what other responsibilities
I think just or is it just like you just
you're kind of the cap like anything
everything kind of flows through you you
know what I'm saying yeah that kind of
thing and I know you probably keep an
open ship like everybody kind of there's
other vets in there that kind of do
their thing but like you're the kind of
the you're just the the guy that's
that's super cool man that's super cool
so do you get any perks like you get to
be I get a nice parking spot at the
stadium yeah it's all right look a
little closer I'm a little closer now to
the door so it helps out it helps out
all right so before before we get deeper
into Aaron we wanna I wanna know who
Aaron judge
was before Aaron judge now so you you
played three Sports in high school what
sports did you play football baseball
and basketball which which sport do you
feel like you were best at
man I love football football for me you
just had a different you have a
different mindset like in football you
get hit man I can get angry and it's
going to help me hit that guy across you
know across from me or go out there and
make a play in baseball you get angry
man and you put up these old highlights
look at you though man you know no we
had we had fun with football man it was
just Friday Night Lights boy I bet man I
remember I didn't play football my mom
didn't let me play football but I was
if there was ever a hall of fame for
water boys
I I mean there was not one man that went
thirsty you know I was there coaches
Anybody Everybody referees I was I was
the best water boy of all time so if you
were in the NFL I'll probably be a great
water boy for you but you're in the MLB
so I I uh Hey speaking of speaking of
you know your mom didn't let you play
that was the same thing with me like I
went into my freshman year high school
walking around campus and the football
coach on me says who are you and why are
you not on my field right now I said I
played I play basketball and baseball I
don't know what to tell you he said come
try out come sign up so I go home tell
my mom dad like hey some football coach
wants me to come travel in the field and
she's like nah no way I'm a mom I'm six
six like I'm bigger than everybody what
like what do you you said this is your
freshman year yeah six six okay cool
okay I'm like what are you what are you
worried about she's like
let's give it a year you stay up on your
grades and maybe as a sophomore you can
go out there so I was fine with my
grades didn't play that freshman year
and then sophomore year I said you can't
you can't fight it now I'm going out
there so so you wanted to play football
yeah because all my friends all my all
my boys growing up were playing football
you know and I usually was playing you
know basketball during the summer all
year round baseball year round so I
really didn't have time to fit you know
football into it and then once I got to
high school it was kind of like
man I got nothing to do on a Friday
night I got I gotta figure something out
okay so so so how how
was there a choice to play football in
college
or did you like for you personally like
did you were you like I may want to play
football in college or was it always
baseball man it was always baseball like
I love basketball I love love football
but baseball just
it was just always in the back of my
mind man I just I just love playing it
yeah like it just the game within the
game that people don't see I always love
that just a chess Mass between the
pitcher and the hitter The Catcher And
The Hitter uh just little things man it
just intrigued me at a young age and and
man you get
you get beat up I mean I know you love
playing basketball like you get beat up
playing basketball running up and down
those courts you get beat up in football
you know every single place so for me I
was thinking more longevity too I was
like hey if I can
you know make something work with this
baseball thing like hopefully I could
have a long career down the road and you
know set up my family for life so you
got drafted didn't go
yeah why didn't you why didn't you why
didn't you want to sign man I don't know
how you gotta dressed out of high school
right I don't know how you guys do that
like like mentally and physically like I
just didn't feel like I was ready yet
you're not you're not I wasn't when I
got drafted I wasn't mine I I decided
purely based off the money I got and
I went and I was I wasn't like I was
calling my boys and crying calling my
mom calling Bree I mean I was crying
like I'm not ready for this half the
people don't speak English you know what
I'm saying and and you go and your 18
year old kid you just went from high
school so you were with everybody two
weeks ago yeah and then you go to a
place where I don't know anybody and you
got to play a game find a way to feel
comfortable to play a game
that you ain't never play and you're a
professional now you know and then
you get a whole bunch of money yeah at
18 years old
you'll know how to really act you know
what I'm saying so my parents
fortunately I was raised in a great
household my parents you know were able
to get hold of me and make sure I was
good my boys make sure I was good and
this and the other but
no you don't so you're right you're
right to that that perspective and what
you just said right there like I think
that's the biggest difference I saw in a
lot of the high school guys and college
guys that made it through Mitch the
major leagues was they had a support
system and they had people around them
family friends that kind of said hey
knucklehead knock that off man yeah you
don't need to be in that like you gotta
you know keep your eye on the prize man
so important because I had so many
friends that in the game like you said
get drafted you make a lot of money also
they're buying everything they want
they're forgetting about investing like
yeah all of a sudden they're done in a
couple years and they don't have they
got a high school diploma they got no
more money it's
it's tough man but like you said like
I'm thankful we both have great parents
and just people around so you ended up
going to college and you had fun in
college
and and got drafted whatever now you're
with the Yankees and you got hurt your
first year how was that like like how
when you were hurt and didn't really
know you were in a professional sport
but couldn't really play like how what
was your mind what was your mind at that
time
right after I got drafted yeah yeah well
I tore my quad in college my junior year
so like my last probably three weeks of
the season I was just the aging and all
the scouts kept asking like why is this
guy the agent and it's like well I
couldn't I couldn't even run around the
bases really and you know we're trying
I'm trying to get drafted trying to
you know I didn't want my you know the
stock to fall whatever it is so we kind
of kept that silence so it was funny I
got got out to Florida Tampa first
couple days like run the bases doing
conditioning stuff and they see me like
kind of hobbling around the bases they
said man what is wrong with you and I
said I got nothing nothing's wrong you
know and they said now go let's go
inside and check something out so it was
tough that first year because you're
like you know top draft pick you know
you want to make a good impression like
you said like you're just meeting all
these new people who are in the same
position you are you want to make a good
impression these are your future
teammates you know and I'm sitting in
here on the training table like it's it
was rough that first year that's why you
know I was
call call my parents all the time call
my agents like you know maybe I should
have went back one more year at Fresno
was just the right decision but
you know it it all worked out eventually
man and God that's at all it always does
yeah and so then you're going through
the minor leagues and when you how was
how was your minor league experience did
you enjoy it or was it like were you
just grinding the whole time no I loved
it you know you got to love that grind
man you know how it is like you got to
love those those ups and downs so for me
my first first year plan was in low way
Charleston you know was there for half
the Year got called up to Haye in in
Tampa and like first half I'm hitting
330 second half when I get up to Tampa
get called up I'm hitting like 240 you
know so that was kind of a grind it's
like I'm hitting 330 like this is this
is pro bowl like yeah I'm gonna be up in
the big soon I'm looking at the roster
like okay I can make it up here and yeah
um you know then you kind of get hit in
the face when you get up to a new level
new pitching new environment game speeds
up just a little bit so it was tough
then the next year starting out double A
everything's going great in double A and
also you get moved up to AAA and the
same thing I'm hitting like 230. you
know kind of a shock and you just see
how close you are to the big leagues but
it still feels so far away but you know
I I enjoyed it man like like I said
earlier like I had so many good friends
around me that I could talk to and when
I wasn't feeling right I'm like man this
I I'm never gonna make it to the big
lease I'm getting struck out you know
three four times in the game and in
Triple A like I'm not gonna expect to go
up in the big leagues and and perform so
it was
it's fun yeah it was fun man yeah I
enjoyed it like so then so then you
you're in the big leagues and
I'm assuming at some point you had you
went through a swing change
I know I did an 18 and I remember
when I went through my swing change that
was the worst spring training I had ever
had in my I think it was like two for 54
or something like that
and it took it took time and I
questioned myself like I don't I'm not
who I am anymore like I don't even know
what's going on I don't even know how to
hit anymore and so I didn't know like
when you went through your swing change
and your your swing your hitting coach
yeah how was that whole process
because for me it sucked until we got to
the time and now you know now I know how
to maintain like exactly and whatever so
it was
it was it was scary man but it was like
a whole off season how long did it take
for you yeah so 2016 in the big leagues
for like two months in the year I hit
179 like brutal getting booed and like
man this the same this ain't for me you
know and
um you know actually with my agent that
brought hey I got this you know hitting
coach and I worked with a little bit you
know near the end of my career he still
works with guys I think you should check
him out I said it's like Dave give me
anybody because I'll take anything over
the 179 and the performance I put out
there so I flew out to Arizona to meet
him actually went with Rob russnyder
who's with the the Red Sox right now we
both came up with him played against
them all yeah oh yeah all the time but
yeah so yeah we got the same agent so
you know we both went out to Arizona
we're hitting in the cage with this guy
and mookie I'm telling you
he watched me hit a little bit and he
said Hey try this this and this
I made a couple changes and bro I'm
telling you like that I hit a couple
balls
it was like instantly different I felt
like
I've never had a baseball like that like
okay because for me like as a big guy I
was taught like
you know kind of Swing more down like
you want hard line drives and I'm like
that's what everybody
that's what everybody yeah that's for me
though yeah that's what people like me
not for you yeah so like I'm sorry like
I started elevating the ball a little
better not I'm not saying like hitting
the top of the net but like just getting
off the ground yeah just getting it off
the ground you know so I remember
getting back in the car with Rob right
after we hit for like an hour or two and
I said
bro I think I'm hitting 50 homers next
year like kind of joking around but I
just I could see the change and like the
difference and also now
for me what helped out too was he was
breaking down videos like hey look at
these like look at these guys in the big
leagues and what they're doing and now
look at your video and what you're doing
so for me that was a cool experience to
be able to finally
like you see your film and you think I
got it figured out but then I'm like
well I don't look like any of these
great hitters right but these guys are
hitting 300 hitting 30 homers a year I'm
hitting 179 with four homers there's a
difference here so getting a chance to
kind of learn how to look at guy's
swings learn how to see like okay when
things are going wrong why is it going
wrong okay well I'm not on legs here I'm
jumping forward or I'm you know not
staying back this just little things
like that so that's spring training you
know show up and you know obviously the
organization wants you to you just hit
179 they have their ideas of how they
want you to change so they kind of gave
me something oh so did they not know
about no they didn't know okay that's
cool I mean yeah that's that's normal so
like I'm in there doing all these funky
drills I'm doing stuff they've never
seen and they're like
you need to widen out like put the ball
in play like you just need to get your
average up and I said guys just trust me
like okay like if I'm gonna go down if
I'm gonna be out of the MLB like I'm
gonna do it my way
let me let me just you know if I fail
this this first year in 17 like that's
on me and then I'll figure something out
so
so it was a little tough like you said
in spring training like people were
questioning it you know I got hitting
coaches kind of on me about this ain't
gonna work cut it out but they're all
looking for your best interests they
want you to succeed so
and so you had so you had to so then
take us take me back to
62. number 62 when you hit it because I
mean you're just hitting home runs right
I mean like at this point I feel like
every time you touch it
it's a homer you know what I'm saying
like every every every Stadium you go to
it's it's like when
it's 200 feet for you yeah I'm saying
you know it's it's kind of not fair but
it is fair too because like hitting is
hard bro you know I'm saying hitting is
hard for no matter what shape size you
are yeah and it just helps to be big but
still to hit you don't just hit power
you like you get hits you walk you do
everything hitting so take me back this
is this is take me through this can we
run this one more time like I want to
know some emotions some feelings like as
soon as you hit it like you know what
was going through your head
man well we could pause it if we could
pause it before this this is the second
game of doubleheader before the last oh
this is game two this is game two and
before that I was literally playing
every single day from
basically July and August you know kind
of going for this I really wasn't going
for it but as a competitor you're like
you know if I just have a good swing to
that bass you know we're gonna have a
chance at this so this is after I don't
know 40 50 games straight you know
mentally beat up physically beat up
you know every game at home Yankee fans
are standing up on their feet they're
cheering before his nerve recognized man
you know
not really nervous but just you don't
want to let the fans down man you know
they want to see something they want to
be a part of History you know they've
been with me through this whole journey
throughout the whole year throughout my
whole career like you want to do it at
home you want to do it in front of those
fans so
no it was tough like I I started leading
off which is which is tough man I don't
know how you do that but like I lead off
the game I hit a double and they're
almost like a sense of like
uh man like so which was weird because
I'm like man we're still trying to win
this game what are we doing here it
wasn't even about the game at that point
for them yeah so for us for me too yeah
exactly so you know finally we get to
this last we got this double header I
remember telling skip he's like hey like
I'm thinking maybe sitting either the
first game or second game I said hey let
me play the first game we'll see how it
goes first game not that I made one for
four I don't know what happened
and he calls me in the office hey like
maybe situ's next game I said no skip
give me
give me another one give me another one
just give me give me give me a chance
here I got a good feeling I got a good
feeling I went straight to the cage I'm
in the cage I'm hitting I'm with our
hitting coaches and uh Casey our
assistant coach is in there with me and
he's like
probably just
relax a little bit it's gonna come if it
comes it comes if it doesn't it doesn't
so in my mind going up to that that's
the first inning my first step back the
second game I said you know what man
like if it happens it happens if it
doesn't it does but you knew it was
going to happen exactly you know you
know what's going to happen but you just
want to get over it you want to get over
with because like even the video like my
teammates jumping on the field the way
they're reacting like they're in it with
me they kind of weren't even talking to
me for a couple weeks either because
they're like we don't want to jinx this
we want to
you know go do your thing it was so was
it like as you're going on this this
pace was it like okay guys I get it I'm
hitting the homers but I just want to be
normal for a little bit like I just
wanna I don't want it to be about that I
want to still play the game I want to
still win the game you know I'm saying
because you seem like that kind of guy
like hey I know I'm doing this but I
also want to keep it on us you know what
I'm saying I think that's why you got to
see yeah you know for sure but they did
a good job of that like you know they
didn't they didn't talk about it they
just talked about the game they talked
about winning okay so for me that helped
me kind of keep my mind off because I go
to my teammates and
you know they knew what was weighing on
me but they never they never wanted to
bring it up and be like hey like how you
doing you're doing all right they're
just kind of like hey could swing their
men are like hey what'd you think of
that play they just they just did a good
job of distracting me man and that's why
you know getting a chance to share a
moment like that you know with my
teammates you reminded with me all years
was so special you spending so much time
with those guys like they know how to
handle they they know you just as much
as you know you you know what I'm saying
so that's good so as you were going were
you like I'm gonna break this record
this year did you ever think to say that
in your head like I'm gonna or was it
just like I don't know that's a lot yeah
it's a lot not really you know because
the media you know two months in are
like oh you're on Pace for 68 homers
this and that I'm like I'm Pace like
what's yeah what's that mean in May that
don't mean nothing for me it may you
know let's let's talk let's talk in
September yep and then as I started
getting closer and closer
they wanted to talk about it but then I
was like man I I got a game to focus on
so it was
it was tough I avoided I didn't say I
avoided the media for a while but they
just didn't see me in my locker until
after the game but so speaking of on
Pace you're they're I'm sure you've
probably heard it you're probably kind
of you're you're back on Pace for again
right
um but there you go right there
and you're not going up there just
trying to hit homers you're just going
up there and hitting I mean there's the
the numbers show you're just going up
there and hitting yeah and I think
that's that's super super dope bro
because hitting has gotten when we when
we first started to now hitting is so
much harder different game bro you're
literally hitting against a computer as
well as you know I'm saying 98 100 98
and 100 you know and that's every night
yes EV every single night so you have
all these personal accolades and then
hmm
for what what do you what do you
contribute a lot of
these personal things do you ever like
take that with the team as well like hey
you know my team is the reason why I'm
able to
be so good you know what I'm saying like
is it do you ever contribute a lot of
that to the to your teammates because
like I said you spend a lot of time with
these guys and for you to go do that
like you had to have that support system
around you oh for sure every and and the
fans as well you know what I'm saying
man every little like that's all the
stats you brought up there
only reason why they're like that is
because the guys I'm hitting behind the
guys I'm hitting in front of like
getting a chance to you know last year
hit behind DJ Le Mayhew all year and
that guy is literally on base two or
three times a night people don't they
don't realize that then they then I
think about you know Anthony Rizzo
Giancarlo Stanton he's Ballin yeah who
are guys that are putting 30 homers out
every year 30 plus homers
um you know so they're giving me a
chance it's like team's got to pick
they're like okay we got Lemay who on
first we have judge up we got Stanton
behind him we got Rizzo behind them like
we really don't want Rizzo or Stanton
coming up with two or three guys on base
like we gotta we gotta pitch of this guy
so you know that happens over the course
of the year you're gonna get better
pitches ahead and
it'll just that's good for me don't
swing and miss so it's always about my
teammates any any awards you get any
team
it's always it's about the team man like
even like you're watching your MVP
season in 2018 man like
you had so many guys on base and yeah
the biggest thing is you just came you
just came up you just did your job but
you didn't overthink it you said your
job you got guys on base well I just got
to drive them in or no one's on base
well I gotta get on base the guys behind
me can drive me in that year JD won two
silver Sluggers man we have that now you
went to yes so so being now that now
that I'm with the Dodgers and we had the
Giants and I guess you could say the
Padres or rivalries you're right
tell me about tell me your take on the
Red Sox Yankees rivalry because I can
tell you mine you know I want to hear
your take on it or actually you know
I'll go first okay okay
I think the Red Sox Yankees rivalry is
is
probably
the best in sports
and I say that because both teams are
always good
and
this may be fan driven but like it seems
like it's always hostile
you know what I'm saying like we play
the Yankees I don't care if we're both
in last or you know we're both tied for
last like it's going to be a hostile
game we're trying to beat you you're
trying to beat us and it's just we'll do
anything to win you know what I'm saying
and so I remember I remember when we uh
when we had our brawl and uh Joe Kelly
had hit Tyler Austin
and I'm in right field I'm like oh my
gosh here we go so so
everybody runs in
y'all are on the field mind you y'all
had everybody that was six five and
taller on your team so I had Tommy
kaneley
who he's he's six two but he's a
wrestler he loves wrestling
then Dylan batances six eight Chapman
Chapman uh Chad green
right behind me yeah in right field they
were coming too
I slowly walked because and I saw them
let me let me let them go first I'm a
lover not a fighter yeah you know what
I'm saying and y'all was too big man but
that that like perfectly depicts the the
Red Sox Yankees Robert so I want to hear
your your your take on it no like you
said every single time we play it didn't
matter if it was a Tuesday in May or a
Friday night at Fenway in you know
September
the place was packed Yankee Stadium was
packed Fenway was packed
and no
the fans just brought it every single
time like they they raised the energy
level from the very first pitch you
could see like when you step in the Box
the guy on the mound is a tick a tick
better like his below is a little up on
both sides everything so it was just
that's what you wanted that's what you
want as a ball player man you want the
best and man I I miss those I'm glad I'm
watching you do your thing at Dodger
Stadium so I'm not seeing you hit you
know home Raptor Homer you know over the
month over my head in right field man
but it was
no it's it's a blast like you said
that's that's the best rivalry in sports
I think have you had did you have like
uh in Boston did you have people like
talking crazy like I know you have
people what's something give me
something good that you hurt
that's kind of yeah you know that you
can say on air
man I think there's the craziest thing
to me is you know I like you play you
warm up in between Innings you know toss
the ball to you know some kids
and I saw a couple kids there with some
Red Sox stuff and I'm like I'll toss
them a ball you know they're kind of
waving like hey toss it to them
and you know kind of just wave it at
them and also they're like they get the
ball look at it and they start flipping
me off saying oh really go Red Sox
honestly man like yeah all right
but that happens man it's you know they
love their team and
um
I'm just looking they didn't throw the
ball back at me but now that happens all
the time that's that's good so all right
so New York La both dope cities
I got some
New York La not this or that but which
one is better New York L.A so I think
okay we'll go better weather
oh it's not even close yeah okay
now this one
is a good one
food
which one has better food because I I
can't La is dope but New York yeah it's
got it's got to be New York I love New
York I love I love coming out here and
getting some some great meals but in New
York you can go to a different spot
every single night and it's going to be
incredible and it's and half the time
there's rats running right in front of
the door
and you go in and it's just the food is
just magnetic that's when you know it's
good when you see when you see that out
front that's when you know it's good
it's all fancy all them nights walking
in New York and I see the trash right
there
and I smell the smell the feces in the
air you know what I'm saying from the
sewers I know I'm getting I know I'm
getting me a good meal I'm getting some
good you got something okay so what
about music
I'm biased to to La man I grew up a
California guy mads New York rappers I
feel like they're good but they be like
aggressive
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
they're kind of aggressive and it's not
you know it works for them that's how
that's how they work but I feel like the
LA is just you know laid back top down
yeah yeah we're laid back lay back and
we some L.A dudes
all right so what about the nightlife
but a nightlife
New York's great but like
you know some of these like rooftop yeah
rooftop bars here scenes you got in La
man it's that's tough to beat on the
summer night any like the the vibe is
different it's like a upscale everybody
dresses up smells nice looks good you
know and then yeah I feel like the uh
clothes the tires different like you're
gonna work you see some people wearing
some crazy stuff here you know I'm sure
you see some crazy in New York as well
but some gonna be off the wall always
always so what about uh I think this is
a great question traffic
because New York got some traffic you
know
I'll take the New York traffic because I
know at any point I can just get out and
I can walk and probably be there here in
L.A yeah you ain't walking nowhere you
stuck on the highway man you ain't going
nowhere what about shopping
that's New York man I think that's New
York I think New York too same thing
like it's all it's all right right there
on Fifth and it's got like all the
stores man yeah they're gonna take all
man they're gonna take all that 360.
especially when you buy your first thing
whatever exactly exactly all right
better place to live yeah and I've heard
not talking talking to Cece he told me
he didn't live in like
I guess nobody really lives in the city
but right outside of it's beautiful like
you don't know where you're in New York
and so I'm curious you know I'm saying
you've been in both you know which one
which one is a better place to live not
talking not taking any any baseball into
accounts yeah
met at La for me I love the weather I
love like you said kind of getting out
of the city like I love living in the
city in New York but
you got to have that little Escape man
right you know I feel like when you're
at the stadium all day and you come back
in the city like you never really turn
it off but here I feel like you can kind
of drive out of the city you can you can
get lost in those Hills man yeah yeah
for sure all right so
what about like which one would have a
better fan base
and I don't know if it would be better I
I don't know to answer that one
I feel like they would be different
because LA's fan base is way they
watched it and they're just more chill
you know what I'm saying if I feel in
New York and even in Boston and I
learned to appreciate it like you you
start struggling
they're going to boo you I don't they
don't care who you are yeah
and
I appreciated that because it made me
strap it on every day yeah I gotta go
perform
you know what I'm saying so what how how
do you feel about that yeah I agree
that's why that's one another reason why
I love playing in New York is because it
doesn't matter who you're playing that
night if it's you know a last place team
coming into town or if your Red Sox are
coming to town la is coming to town
like the fans are going to bring it like
if you are if I'm over three that night
also now I'm over for the punch punch
out walking back to the Dugout they're
gonna let me know like yeah man I paid
all this money to come watch you do
something you ain't do nothing
you got to pick it up which which like
you said like it makes you strap it on
every single night like you got to bring
it because these fans are watching they
know the game they understand the game
they understand what you're going
through because they they know the stats
they know how you've been hitting how
you haven't been hitting so for me I
appreciate that because you know they're
right there in the corner with you so
when you have a big Homer to win the
game and they're right there with you
cheering they're gonna be they they
you're on top of the world exactly but
if you have you ground into a double
play in the game they're gonna let you
go too Barry yeah so that's super cool
that's super cool so all right so I got
some fan questions
favorite picture to face and who's your
favorite picture to face and it's you
know everybody just has a guy
that you just love facing because you
know when you face him I'm going deep
and this says no shade to anybody else I
can't I can't say it man I I can't I
can't say it I can't say I want to jinx
it I don't want to jinx it you know well
I'll tell you mine I'll tell you mine
let me hear it you remember Danny Duffy
yeah I got to play with him I talked to
him
and no matter when I was facing Danny
Duffy
I knew I was going deep he could not
keep me in the yard and he knew it he
knew it and so you know
that I'll say my guy you don't have to
say your guy you don't want to jinx it I
feel it that's the superstitious part
that baseball players have that you guys
don't understand because you know I'm
saying we just don't want to say it and
then now we go oh for 10 against this
guy and we feel like saying it is what
Jack did it's a humbling game yeah and
it will it very well it very well could
so who's your least favorite pitcher to
face
least favorite pitcher to face I don't I
just don't want to face him
man it's my boy it's my boy with the
raise Tyler glass now man like he's
and you know I think we scored like what
one or two on them and I mean he's just
he's just good he's good man and that's
the thing is I came up playing against
him I played with them in the fall
league you know got to see him with
Pittsburgh and then once he got over to
the raise and really started figuring
things out man but he's he's as tall as
me yeah it feels like he's just dropping
the ball off in the catcher's glove he's
got that big curveball looks just like
the heater he's working on like that
little cutter slider thing it's didn't
wasn't he like an Olympic or uh his
parents or something where his mom or
something like that okay because he's a
super good athlete like he did backflips
and uh super really good athletes oh
yeah yeah you can tell by the way he
pitches because he's you know athletic I
got I got a question for you though
you came up as a second baseman oh yeah
yeah yeah and then you're gonna just
move to the Outfield yeah and when every
gold glove and then also be like you
know what I want to play some I want to
play some you need me a short you need a
short stop I'll move the short real
quick return double plays like it ain't
nothing like how when I when I just
moved to center field or move to left
like that's
that's still an outfield position but
that's still a tough adjustment from but
to go from The Outfield to the infield
the next day you're playing right yeah
but I don't I don't know how that so
when I was
playing Summer Ball coming up not even
this is in high school
I didn't have one team I played on
I had like four teams I played on and
the reason why is because I split a lot
of my time
playing basketball
so I wasn't even playing baseball all
the time and so I would go to like
two basketball tournaments to one
baseball tournament um
and so I was just like you know I'm not
gonna play this week and then that's how
I
we got began to be on four teams so they
would call me like hey we need a third
baseman this week can you come play
yeah I'll go play we need we need to
come play short this week we need to
come play second this week I need you to
come play center this week and so I grew
up doing it and then I got drafted as a
shortstop
and when I
got dry I only played like 15 games
and then I got moved to second base and
then I went all up through the minor
leagues at second base and infill is my
life bro it's my life it's the most fun
I have planned and so when I got moved
to right it was like
all right well I'm gonna be the best
right fielder like I can be you know
what I'm saying because we're gonna
apply ourselves exactly it's hard yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna be the best fried
Pro I can be and
so I just got really good at it and um I
kind of got stuck out there did they
come to you and say like hey we got
Dustin Pedroia a second yeah they had
just signed bogey a short like
you're gonna be in the big leagues with
like
we're gonna put you in the Outfield and
then that that was it that that's how
that's how I play and now being able
that I'm a little older now and I get to
there was a hole there was a lot of
things had to be right for me to end up
playing short and second but you know it
ended up being right and I've had the
best time of my life so so if I see if I
get to play in field I see you gonna
chop it up while we're out there so let
me out let me let me ask a couple more
fan questions you're Mount Rushmore of
Yankee greats
oh Yankee grades
I gotta go Yogi Berra 10-time World
Series champ man that's
that's unheard of
uh Mickey Mantle you know Mick man just
the MVPs what he did every single year
playing center field
Babe Ruth obviously
and
Jeter the captain yeah man just because
I got a chance to see him growing up and
you know what he did for the game you
know not only
just how he played the game how he
treated every single day the
competitiveness I guess that's what it's
about man so I I would say for us to Rap
Man like
I think that's why you got to see on
your chest
well on your arm
because you do those same things now
let's remember that bro like and I know
you will you know you know you Aaron
judge right but you know I had to learn
these last couple years like I can't
ever question
myself you know what I'm saying and so
we go through these struggles and we go
through all these things and you know
we're going through life in general I
know I don't know if whenever you decide
to have kids and all those type of
things like You're Gonna I'm not gonna
say you're gonna get lost but you just
sometimes you kind of question yourself
bro and just remember you got to see you
got everything everything is great for
you bro and it's super super dope to
watch especially to see you stay out of
the media see how when you're in the
media it's for positive things and so I
just want you to know like you know for
for the rest of us normal people you
know what I'm saying you're super dope
man you're super inspiring for us and
and the kids as well so but I gotta say
the same thing Luke like you man you
kind of paved the way you know what I'm
saying like coming up at a young age and
like
like you said bro like every single time
I'd watch you play against us or watch
you on TV like you were coming up in big
moments but you're never like the guy
making it about you no it's never about
you bro it's about your teammates
helping your teammates out man and
seeing that like you're a superstar
you're the best player in the field but
you still made it about everybody else
around you man that's where I think
that's such a good lesson for the kids
see me yes sir just remember that
everyone happiness lies with everyone
else then it comes to you that's it on
base for Mookie Betts and a a Ron judge
[Music]